I'm doing this we're gonna read an old
an old favorite of mine it should go
100% they just announced that they're
making the Ichigo monomers and manga
receives a sequels in April it's time to
catch up
Ichigo 100% oh my god it's a love story
it's it's a beautiful love story I have
ever read in my life
Romeo and Juliet excuse me I didn't have
any clue what to film today so I thought
hey why don't I just go through the old
manga just for the sake of nostalgia I'm
scared because I feel like this is an
awful god-awful idea of a video another
thing I had seen anyone sink this low
this is Peter Pyatt 2017 ending everyone
[ __ ] bad idea after crossing that do
not entertain
sorry climbing the remaining 18 steps if
you opened the heavy door the most
beautiful view in town I was wondering
why did that all the schools keep the
roof unlocked in anime every time a foot
question mark what what is about to
happen this one was my favorite I always
shipped I was shipped her and the main
guy yeah I don't know what I don't know
what he's saying
but you know I think he he shoved his
face into that girl's asked somehow I
don't
can you imagine opening a door this way
and somehow your face end up in a girl's
ass well only in Japan only in Japan and
now he killed her somehow who is this
girl now I remember why I like this
Banga did she die
this is this is like for 16 year olds I
think you have to be 16 2 or 14 I don't
know like what's the age on this
strawberry panties it should go 100% huh
he's just going full power on this girl
the fields the first time they met the
wind just are the skirts that short in
Japan I don't think so yeah doing a
great job with the voices here she runs
off was it something I did well it could
have been the fact that you shoved your
face into her [ __ ] she's the one who
fell down I'm the one who's surprised is
he seriously mad about that anyway
was there a beautiful girl like that at
our school so beautiful standing in the
Evening Sun with her skirts waving you
literally just checked out her ass ah
it's a killer scene getting up the
camera has to be in slow motion what is
he talking about wait isn't this just an
erotic video come to think of it she was
up here okay so she fell down in front
of him I wonder what she was doing
hmm this is actually fun this to be fun
third year class for Tojo aya class for
this is our class I have no idea maybe
it's not her notebook wait so this girl
is in your class but you never noticed
her and tell her ass was in your face
typical men oh well I have to find the
owner tomorrow huh a beautiful girl
wearing strawberry panties right what
would you call it an angel from heaven
and she truly is that scene where I saw
the girl turning is more beautiful than
any other movie I've seen manakish being
crazy again
but if Monica is this excited she must
have been really beautiful girl Monica
that was his name I remember now coming
back to me yes the only girls he talks
about are from movies anyway eight great
movies what does that mean a mannequin
you picked the girls notebook right
what's her name
come on tell us I couldn't care if it
was someone on Komiyama
but fukusa you're popular with the girls
so I don't want to tell you what do you
mean my level well you look like surgery
went wrong you look like a Street
Fighter character ah come on
I'm not that popular and right now my
mind's only on soccer talk in this
direction
yeah he's the [ __ ] so amazing I'm set to
go to Izumi Sokka high school as a
student on the soccer program thanks for
telling us that that's very useful
Monica didn't you say you were going to
sue me Sokka yeah hurry up and tell us
so you can concentrate on your exams
we'll help you actually it belongs to
someone in my class do you guys know her
her name's Joe Joe Joe Joe Hiatt Danny I
shipped them so hard okay I shipped them
harder than anything
Joe Joe yeah I think there was a girl
like her oh there is really why is it so
hard for me to remember girls faces and
names because you only see them further
potay will already be graduating middle
school soon they're in middle school I'm
sorry I don't think the owner of this
book it's the girl with the strawberry
panties
that's her she's like Superman and Clark
Kent she wears the braids and the
glasses what if I'm not doing that Moyes
what you've you found my math notes
[Music]
did he expect someone else I was looking
for it since yesterday
thanks Menaka but I'm so relieved you
found it Oh
oh no look at me sorry if you don't have
to help me it has to be a different
person I'm sure I never knew tosia was
this plane that girl what about my notes
oh yeah your notes sorry I forgot them
good job good job man what I mean what
what it it doesn't matter
we don't have math today I'll definitely
bring it tomorrow okay but those notes
have is he trying to look up her skirt
to see if it was her no I won't look at
her panties
hey Monica you didn't look right yeah I
didn't look please you cannot look okay
right Monica why am I doing this I don't
how you see she doesn't want him to see
yours it should go panties my writing is
so messy I don't want anyone to see it
oh she's talking about her notes all
right
I will look at them you're being serious
right Manaka
I'll do that it's my turn to clean today
anyway NEA no this is the the the real
subs okay this is not a it's okay might
as well this is actually pretty heavy
come on the bells ringing okay in the
end it was all for nothing
hey I've been thinking what it's a demon
who is a demon guys she want to die yeah
he does look [ __ ] weird I don't know
maybe Monica saw Nishino tsukasa from
class to think about it how many shiny
beautiful girls SARS like that could
there be it this one school he may be
right su casa it's damn it man you speak
about her whenever you get the chance
shut up
what can I do I like her for anyway
what about su casa it's possible to Casa
I don't [ __ ] know but what does
machine Nishi know that's the blonde
girl's name I remember now
I don't ship her okay he needs to be
with Tojo you how can you not know the
most beautiful Idol in our school it's a
sin to not know what she looks like like
a sin it's so Whaley written that I
can't read it
ah save me Oh Cass boo Khoosat oh good I
don't [ __ ] know he's just not
interested in girls
he just loves Japanese dick sorry stop
it
you guys are so noisy anyway I also
think the strawberry panties girl is
Tsukasa sad let's go see what she looks
like
Manaka of course we'll go but it's
definitely her right her hair was semi
long and she was wearing a third-year
uniform right and if it really is an
amazing beauty the first thought is to
keep Tsukasa but you didn't even know my
favorite girl but are you gay YouTube's
permits it has nothing to do with like
or dislike just talking about her
[ __ ] underwear I simply want to film
the moment that girl's panties win him
it was the filming all right I remember
the guys into filmmaking he wants to
film
he was the film or panties you're 15 the
[ __ ] I mean not panties her skirt just
her skirt sure buddy it doesn't matter
if it's the panties or skirt ah
Manaka is a big pervert they're running
away from him because he said that it's
a mistake this is art I'm seeking art if
you want to talk about being a permit
Komiyama it's a much bigger pervert than
me it's a well-known fact did you say
that I'm a pervert you are a pervert
always talking about Tsukasa and you
only think about girls my feelings are
very pure and healthy I'm not like you
who doesn't even know it's su casa su
casa can you swear that you never
imagined su casa in her panties only
someone who's never been in love before
would think that way and you are only in
a one-sided relationship don't look down
on one-sided love
have you ever thought about a girl so
much that you cry on your pillow have
you I'm not doing that much I'm moved by
your confession better here in the
corridor please find a more obscure
place to confess okay
he's not confessing to you you
self-absorbed [ __ ] alright toot toot
toot toot toot it's okay
God I'd really hate guys like you Turkey
cut her hair short so cute this
hairstyle really suits you thank you for
your compliment don't worry about this
guy Sookie
hey sorry I'm not interested in a guy
who looks like a dinosaur yes that's
true I don't I don't like dinosaurs
looking guys he meant either I mean I
don't like guys and you the one thinking
about pancakes every night look I'm
wearing strawberry panties today don't
you ever think about these kind of
things today but you just told him
actually I want to say something bang
but I find myself unable to speak what
is what is with this guy hey come to
your senses class is about to start
why's everyone wearing strawberry
panties the mystery the drama of the
passion I really think it's her her
hairstyle is different but I had lifted
her skirt she didn't look like someone
who would hide it in fact she seemed to
remind me a lot and told me directly
what she was wearing
hey even if you are right I can't
believe su casa su casa would wear the
same underwear for two days yeah that is
pretty gross no I can't accept that it's
only two days my record was five days
don't compare yourself with her hey you
scums is Miss a dinosaur don't you guys
have any sympathy for someone who's just
been rejected
can you guys ignore me just because
you've solved the mystery of the
strawberry panties forget this guy was
here hey come on
I have finally known Tsukasa beauty I
get all embarrassed just thinking about
her
so you finally understand then you
confess to what confess to to constitute
I was rejected because of you
Hey Manaka confessed like me and get
rejected to have a taste of the pain I
feel yeah that makes sense that
definitely makes sense how is that my
fault it's your faces fault yeah you
just need to confess to her hey who
cares okay I'm not sure what you were on
about but you want tsukasa's panties on
tape right
tell her the bared bone truth if she's
not even your girlfriend why would she
let you that's a good good point that's
true Bukka su casa has never fallen for
a confession she's the toughest of the
tough
even I was rejected but there are no
rumors of her dating you never know
unless you try you're right then I'll
have to take that bull by its horns
if I succeed I'll be the boyfriend of
our year's greatest Idol okay I'll do it
for my ambitions this make no [ __ ]
sense I hope you get rejected
I won't get rejected but how will I find
the time to think of a confession I'm a
busy third year still if I'm going to
confess anyway I hope it goes well
yesterday I was only thinking of
strawberry panties girl toe I it's an
issue Tsukasa
what am i doing if I had a video camera
my first shot would definitely be that
girl in the sunset please don't look at
it she might have said that but her
writing is so neat why would she say to
not look at it because of the contents
I'm not interested in towards you I am
yes you are yes you are but she might
have written about a guy she likes I'm
sorry I yeah it's packed full of notes
I'm might be able to copy a few this is
what is it what is it what is it I mean
no
okay next morning morning good morning
ah
Manaka I was thought his name reminds me
of pancake pan at pinaka Fang Kaka about
my math notebook today Anaka
hey Menaka are we on the roof Manaka
this is so beautiful
I was so shocked you really are amazing
this is so dramatic I love it your notes
I read them what you promised you
wouldn't read them yesterday
I was so hooked on the novel you wrote I
am I was so amazed you really are a
genius you have more sense it's not
finished right and where's the hero and
the stone doll I'm going have you
thought about it yet you won't laugh
right I'm still dreaming what it's
boring though right and it's childish I
just scribble whatever came to me in my
studies I didn't want to show anyone
it's a guilty pleasure I was just using
it as a means to escape my studies when
I became tired
this is embarrassing don't say that if
you say that then you're also denying me
this is so [ __ ] like I don't know why I
like this so much this is buggin ah oh
yeah don't you want to become a novelist
you can write amazing stories it would
be a waste if you don't if you didn't if
I told you my dream you would laugh I
wonder what it would be like to not
fulfilling because of this I don't even
tell my friends but still I'll tell you
I want to make my own movies filming
Europe under way sorry he didn't say
that but when I saw your notes I got
really excited I was only reading the
worst but I would it was like I was
watching a movie you know the scene
where the legendary mage rises the races
the golem in the middle of the desert
after capturing the image of the golem
from the ground looking at the rest of
it has to be captured from above from
the point of the flying dragon well can
you picture it
[Music]
beautiful I came up here after school as
well
were you writing your stories here I
come here at lunchtime I might as well
enjoy the Sun if it if there's no wind
if only you had drop your notes earlier
why because we would have been able to
talk about this earlier
Manaka I are you producing anything
seaman nothing I didn't have have a
video camera if I pass my high school
exam they promise that they buy me one
ha ha hey which high school are you
going to go to I am my first preference
is Umi Academy that's a girl only high
school can't you go to a co-ed one like
Izumi Sokka I guess the level is too low
right and I can't even get into that
school without a miracle damn sure I
won't be able to read the next part of
the novel I want to know how the love
story and the protagonist ends there's a
girl with the same target that's the
main character or the prince is known to
be more beautiful than anyone who will
eat shoes
well I don't watch romantic movies so I
can't imagine it back
speaking of romance since you're here
I'll ask you aiya how do you
successfully confess to a girl yes good
question
Hey this is so sudden I I don't oh it's
not that I'm not confessing to you ayah
wow so nice so smoothly I'm not
confessing to you you ugly [ __ ]
do you know Nishino de su casa from the
class tube I have a situation and have
to confess to her I don't really know
why you don't know why oh look how sad
she gets I guess su casa is very pretty
yeah so pretty that whenever our eyes
cross it's like my body turns to stone
is there a similar monster
then how about confessing as you're
doing sports what a guy who just well at
sports is really attractive right and if
you do sports then you'll be nice less
nervous I'm joking
that's great no it's not oh yeah you
think of it on another level okay
wait I'll be waiting for the next part
of your novel oh my god this is not
gonna end well what look a sad sheis
confession setup you already know how
you're going to confess you've been
working hard how is that like a thing
you work hard on anyway yeah I'm
confident too I'm going to get rejected
anyway the confession method is a bit
anyway I'm so nervous look forward to it
the impact is going to be amazing hmm
Manaka are you looking forward to the
girl or just a mess that up confession
thing yeah that's a good question
I don't know I told you I'm so nervous
right now
hey if that guy wants to date he'll have
to wait another 10 years yeah that seems
about right then he can shoot porn us as
well yeah should I ask
if' for a movie script next you know
toes uija right the girl with the black
rim glasses she fell down and spilt
water all over herself she's the bane of
sport clothes what does that mean huh if
she was cute and clumsy I wouldn't care
but it's like a pumpkin is clumsy I
can't stand her wow so mean what the
[ __ ] I isn't a pumpkin huh why are you
taking her side that's right stand up
for her I isn't ugly if you took her if
she took off her glasses and cut her
hair she could be beautiful too how do
you know that what is this are you
interested in that pumpkin a person
isn't all about their outer appearance
don't talk behind her back if you don't
even know her wait if she took off her
glasses she really could be but it oh my
god I remember this I remember this why
did he call her to the bars I'm not sure
I didn't hear that much it doesn't
matter I'm going to shoot maracas
rejection with this state-of-the-art
camera Komiyama man you are evil this is
why no girls like you or even even is
watching huh that is that
Annika okay he's coming me me me me me
she know to Casa this is where it begins
let's go my neck out did you pay half
dead with my intense pull up and I will
move su casa ice cold heart what the
hell is he doing mannequin you have no
Saints I like you nice unit together
let's go out top 10 anime confessions of
all time she laughs okay if it's you
it's okay
wait she actually said yes and that's
chapter one of Ichigo 100% wow wow this
is a good idea
leave a like poking out if you enjoyed
let me know if you didn't I'm sorry so
hey a lot of stuff happens okay I think
it's good maybe I don't know if I still
like it today but I don't know I don't
know I don't know I don't know what I'm
doing guess this is a bonus video take
it for what it is brofist